Democrats say the impeachment trial of
President Donald Trump is the first
trial in US history without witnesses
it's this a fair trial without the
ability to call witnesses and produce
documents the answer is clearly and
unequivocally no but despite hours of
arguments trying to convince Republican
senators to allow new witnesses in the
trial the yeas are 49 the nays are 51
the Democrats lost all the two
Republican senators voted no it's a
grand tragedy America will remember this
day unfortunately where the Senate did
not live up to its responsibilities
where the Senate turned away from truth
and went along with a sham trial
Democrats had hoped to get the support
of moderate Republican lisa murkowski
but in the end she rejected the idea
saying in a statement I have come to the
conclusion that there will be no fair
trial in the Senate I don't believe the
continuation of this process will change
anything
it is sad for me to admit that as an
institution the Congress has failed this
means
the Senate jury has essentially sealed
its ears to John Bolten Trump's former
national security adviser in his
soon-to-be released book bolton
reportedly says trump asked him to help
pressure ukraine for dirt on political
opponents and tide you a security aide
to the requests trump has denied the
reports his attorneys argue even if true
Trump should still not be impeached so
this idea that they haven't had
witnesses is that's the smokescreen
you've heard from a lot of witnesses the
problem with the case the problem with
their position is even with all of those
witnesses it doesn't prove up an
impeachable offense the articles fail
the impeachment trial now nears its end
with Trump's acquittal all but certain
given that Republicans hold the majority
Trump's political fate more likely lies
in the hands of
American voters who will decide in
November whether to give him a second
term Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera
Washington